- Does this look weird?
- [Adam] What?
- Yes.
I'm uh, tuckin' my boner up.
- Oh, yeah, no.
I've been tucked up since junk.
Actually, the metal in my
belt's pokin' a little bit.
It hurts.
- Guys.
What is the plan?
- Obviously, we're just
gonna go in the bathroom,
masturbate, maybe once
maybe twice, who knows.
Try to get everything out.
Come back out here, get on the
phones and be sales monsters.
- You're gonna crank
down here at the office?
You think that's a smart idea?
- People take smoke
breaks all the time.
- Yeah, so we'll
take a stroke break.
- You can get fired for this.
- Well, if it makes you feel
better, we'll ask Alice first.
- That's the worst
idea than just doing it
all by its own.
- You're being a child.
And that's weird,
because you're one of
the oldest people I know.
Blake, shall we?
- You're doing it now?
Okay.
This I gotta see.